elisabeth ville est passée du calme à la
fièvre puis de la fièvre au drame
l'arrivée des casques bleus de monsieur
amar ch n'avait sans doute pas été
accueillie avec beaucoup de ferveur mais
leur utilisation brutale envie de faire
céder monsieur tshombe est de faire
rentrer le katanga dans le sein d'un
congo unifié a fait lever la tempête ce
pas à elisabethville les casques bleus
sont en difficulté dans le reste du pays
et l'on pense dans le monde que monsieur
achats outrepassé son mandat est
déconsidéré la fonction de l'onu
mais monsieur h n'aura pas survécu à la
crise katangaise qu'il avait soulevé le
secrétaire général de l'onu que son
prédécesseur monsieur trick veulent y
avait accueilli à new york en 1953 est
mort dans un accident d'avion alors
qu'il allait converser avec monsieur
tshombe déjà rencontré l'an dernier des
moyens de faire cesser les combats et
d'arrêter les progrès de la tragique ce
faisant monsieur h qui avait mis l'onu
dans un mauvais qu'à tenter sans doute
d'en circonscrire les effets néfastes
le tragique accident dont il vient
d'être victime va-t-il hâter le
dénouement de la faire ce qui est
certain c'est que la disparition du
secrétaire général de l'onu va apporter
d'autres perturbations à l'onu
précisément
négociations sur berlin mais dans
quelles conditions elles se comptent
examiner les ministres des affaires
étrangères des états unis france grande
bretagne et allemagne
comme l'a dit monsieur couve de murville
la question n'est pas de savoir s'il
faut négocier mais s'il est possible de
négocier avec la russie
[Musique]
conrad adenauer ou willy brandt c'est
entre ces deux hommes que la partie se
joue et la partie c'est à dire les
élections de l'allemagne fédérale qui
désignait les 497 député du futur
bundestag
conrad adenauer 85 ans chancelier depuis
douze ans et leader de la démocratie
chrétienne l'a emporté une fois encore
mais son gouvernement ne possède plus la
majorité absolue il devra composer avec
les libéraux
toujours d'après à cap canaveral les
américains réussissent et le lancement
d'une fusée atlas porteuse d'une capsule
mercure d'un poids de 2 tonnes contenant
un astronaute robot désigné sous le nom
de simulateurs d'équipage et qui
respirent transpirent et exprime ses
sensations la récupération s'est opéré
dans les meilleures conditions doit-on
voir maintenant que le vol de gagarine
américain n'est pas loin
meccano en france vont ils faire une
cure de rajeunissement
on les a tous fait un peu oublier c'est
vrai mais voici qu'on a fait une
remarque et une comparaison la remarque
marseillais la porte naturelle sur
l'afrique et l'orient de l'europe
industrielle or l'acheminement des
marchandises du nord vers le sud ou du
sud vers le nord ses expositions à des
manutentions complexes d'abord à l'usagé
obligé du rail ensuite tous deux coûteux
pour les matériaux pondérons la
comparaison rotterdam à l'autre bout de
l'europe transite un tonnage de très
loin supérieur mieux encore il y flotte
plus de pavillons méditerranéen qu'à
marseille c'est dire que le trafic
préfère la route la plus longue via
gibraltar
un regard sur l'activité du port de
rotterdam donne la clé de ce mystère ici
les matériaux passe directement du
navire qui les apportent dans les
péniche accostée bord rapport car il
existe là un réseau de navigation très
complet vers cette europe industriels
qui s'appelle la ruhr l'allemagne la
belgique voire la lorraine et ce réseau
a nommé les plus lourds de péniches qui
allie la puissance à l'économie les
nécessaires écluses apparaissent
aujourd'hui dans ce système comme de
véritable ascenseur géant rapide
efficace
en regard la france n'offrent que
quelques tronçons à grand débit et pour
le reste un réseau de canaux al'allure
filiforme
les écluses qui ne joignent pas
l'efficacité au pittoresque de leurs
mécanismes folklorique bien heureux
quand ses écluses ne s'alignent pas à
perte de vue tous les 50 mètres des
canaux en définitive qui datent du
siècle dernier étrangler parfois vous à
petite vitesse sous peine d'endommager
les rides un décor bucolique 102 mais
aussi parfois l'oubli
[Musique]
et
des ports ainsi ce sont rouillées des
usines sont mortes faute de
l'approvisionnement bon marché que leur
avaient apporté des matières premières a
mené à peu de frais par les canaux
autant de constatation qui ont fait
naître un grand projet un projet qui
s'appuie sur la canalisation du rhône
l'acce navigables méditerranée mer du
nord par la moselle et parlera des
réalisations déjà jalonnent cette grande
voie nord-sud le grand canal d'alsace
par et attendre le rajeunissement c'est
à dire l'agrandissement du canal du
rhône au rhin les travaux de la
canalisation de la moselle devrait
aboutir en 1963
et au long du grand canal d'alsace on
peut déjà apercevoir les effets produits
sur ses rives par une telle voie
navigable la naissance du sinn nouvelle
lyon où les chemins de fer par est
aujourd'hui saturée trouverait une
nouvelle source d'opulence dans
l'ouverture de l'axé nord sud capables
de donner enfin la vie au moderne port
edouard herriot inutile dans son
isolement
quant à marseille son avenir en serait
évidemment bouleversé puisque les
péniches pourrait venir relayer
directement les navires et en fret enfin
véritablement la tête de ligne de
l'europe
oui
bien qu'il ait été baptisé par les
météorologistes d'outre-atlantique dan
au féminin à l'image de tous les
cyclones et ouragans de ces dernières
années le dernier en date car là
puisqu'il faut l'appeler par son nom ne
laissera que de mauvais souvenirs son
approche avait jeté la terreur en
louisiane et au texas c'est par
centaines de milles comme des bêtes ont
fui devant lui balayant la côte du golfe
du mexique à la vitesse effrayante de
250 km heure carla a marqué sa route de
ruines qui font de lui l'un des plus
destructeurs des ouragans de tout le
xxème siècle
nous
m
des villes ont été effacés de la carte
et pour tous ceux les évacuer d'hier qui
regagne ce qui fut leur toit c'est un
spectacle poignant qui les attend 31
morts dénombrait de nombreux disparus
des dégâts matériels évalués pour
l'instant à 50 milliards d'anciens
francs quel est le bilan encore
provisoire hélas de l'ouragan karl
que dakar connaissent les inondations
l'événement s'il peut se produire est
tout de même assez rare pour qu'on le
remarque des pluies d'une abondance
inaccoutumée ont en effet provoqué dans
les faubourgs de dakar des inondations
heureusement sans gravité mais l'on a
connu dans ces quartiers les scènes
typiques d'un monde envahi par l'eau
quasi non des routes coupées voitures
transformées en barque à moteur le
cortège traditionnel de l'inondation
sous tous les climats rien de tragique
heureusement
[Applaudissements]
ces concours de pompier n'est pas un
épisode de la guerre froide bien qu'il
se déroule à voronej et qu'il met en
scène les étés njord incendie de toutes
les russies
tout le problème est ici un problème de
vitesse et ses équipes qu'elles soient
de moscou de krasnodar de rostov sur le
don d'une vision assez nette de la
question qu'il s'agisse du déroulement
des tuyaux ou du parcours du pompier
style parcours du combattant
m
mais tout cela n'est rien en regard de
l'épreuve d'ascension avec échelle
mobile voyait plus tôt
[Musique]
oh